foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
over two decades probably not long
enough is it 22 years for trying to
overthrow the government of the United
States plotting
for Stewart Rhodes the leader of the
proud boys and Donald Trump
Enrique tario tried to pretend like he
had remorse yesterday of course these
proud boys don't have remorse domestic
terrorists don't normally have remorse
they just don't
I mean it's a general rule I mean we
watched one of the brown boys the other
day he's like yeah I'm so sorry and then
at the end when the judge left he said
Trump won
the judge wasn't buying Enrique Tarios
[__] yesterday judge Kelly who I
believe I believe is a trump appointee
which is kind of funny you know in this
whole
storyline
and a lot of people yesterday were
really [__] pissed off that kelly
didn't give judge kelly didn't give
Enrique tario you know a lot more time
this is kind of it's you know I'm gonna
get into it this morning but this is
kind of what I was talking about
yesterday when I was talking about the
14th thing
you know a lot of people were oh boy
really upset that I was saying stuff
that's
true
just because someone else is saying it
and who it is saying it doesn't mean
it's gonna happen
just like Enrique tario didn't receive
33 years even though that's what the
prosecutors wanted
that's what you wanted
we got to stop setting ourselves up for
disappointment and disengagement because
that's the important thing here and
again that's why I keep saying what I'm
saying
and why I'll continue to say it I don't
care what comments get slung at me and
who speaks out against me I don't give a
[__]
we can not lose our engagement
and I'm telling you disappointment
breeds disengagement
it breeds it
we saw that in 2016. when when there is
a huge swath of the country of the
democratic voting Bloc that was very
disappointed that Bernie Sanders didn't
have a chance to win
they wanted him to win really bad it was
such a great dream to have Bernie
Sanders be the nominee
it could have it could have been but it
wasn't going to happen it never was
going to happen
and disappointment bread disengagement
that's what it does in democracy
I don't care I don't care how you shape
it
and I'm telling you if we don't stay
vigilant against our disappointment
because that's what I'm talking about we
have to stay vigilant against our
disappointment
Justice is coming for these
[__]
it's been coming for them since they
tried to overthrow our government
the reason why Mike Pence
didn't do what Donald Trump wanted is
because Mike Pence he didn't care about
the Constitution he was looking for any
way to do it folks
just like I said last week everyone's
like Brian Kemp doesn't have the power
to Pardon someone in Georgia he's going
they're gonna look for it though
Mike Pence Mike Pence called Dan quell
the former vice president he was so
desperate for someone to tell him yeah
you can just you can just Crown Trump
King
it was a dumb idea it was the dumbest
idea ever you knew it I knew it [__]
Pence knew it
Enrique tario knew what they were doing
give me a [__] break they knew what
they were doing they were meeting in a
parking garage the night before when he
wasn't supposed to be in DC to plot
the Trump coup the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup
he knew what he was doing
that's why the judge didn't buy his
remorse [__] but again you know I
mean a lot of people are disappointed I
posted yesterday on YouTube and on
social media that in re the moment he
got 22 years I pretty much posted it
immediately to let you guys know because
I know we were talking about it
yesterday and I knew that's probably
what we're going to be talking about
today
and the number one comment was it's not
enough time of course I believe that I
think that too
but that's not how Justice works
I mean we can sit here and say that yeah
okay yeah great great great great great
great
22 years is a long time in a federal
prison
again it's probably not enough for what
he did I'll agree to that I mean the
prosecutors wanted 30 30 years you
should probably land somewhere in the
middle between what Stuart Rhodes got
and what they wanted probably with
Enrique tario which again Stewart Rhodes
wasn't enough either I believed I
thought that shirt roads would get what
Enrique agario got I believe I said it
on the show that I thought he would get
21 22 years
Stuart Rhodes and I I I think I said the
other day I think he'll get over 20
years Enrique tario
and the reason why Enrique tario really
got 22 years is because he wasn't at the
Capitol
that's why he got 22 years
dude was The Mastermind he was the one
encouraging his supporters to go commit
the violence
he was the top of the food chain when it
came to the proud boys those that group
of domestic terrorists
but we have to stay vigilant against
disengagement and and discouragement
we have to that's why I come here every
day with the cathartic outrage that's
why I yell and scream my [__] head
off
that's why I point out the danger to you
guys you guys don't need me to tell you
how great Biden is or how great he's
doing
because that's just what it is
what we have to do in this country is
point out to Americans everywhere the
danger
Joe Biden and the Democrats are no
danger to democracy
they may have arguments about how much
minimum wage is supposed to be right how
far Health Care is supposed to go in
this country
those are all debates that we can have
if
if we get fascism to hide back
underneath this rock
it's the only way
there's only one there's only one one
priority right now
and it's to fend off fascism from
destroying our democracy
and yesterday was a step in that
direction
watching the leader of the proud boys
get the biggest sentence
since this all started when Trump said
proud boys stand back and stand by
well he's going to be standing by for 22
[__] years
all at the behest of trump
to overthrow a democratic election
because these [__] boneheads still
don't believe and know that they live in
a democracy they have no clue
they've been brainwashed
[__] brainwashed into believing that
it's only a republic
I mean it is a republic which is a form
of democracy
just like yesterday when I was telling
you about Glenn
saying the 14 [__] yeah is it a
possibility I mean sure a secretary
could State a state could try this [__]
it probably won't fly into court if you
want to know the honest truth
I mean Glenn can say whatever the [__]
he wants and anyone can say whatever the
[__] they want but at the end of the day
the court will decide that decision
because we've never had a secretary of
state have to have to not put
a presidential candidate on a ballot
because of the 14th Amendment because
they try to overthrow the government
before they're convicted of it
it's never happened before hmm
but let me tell you something let me let
me give you
why I said what I because a lot of
people were mad yesterday
and I get it I get it that you like you
like Glenn and Glenn's a smart guy Glenn
knows what he's talking about the
problem is is when he says stuff
that is misinformation because what he
was saying that that's misinformation
that's what that is
oh but Tony it could happen
yeah so so could the possibility of Mike
Pence
overthrowing the government in the name
of Donald Trump
you got it that could have happened too
they could have tried it he could have
tried it what stopped Mike Pence from
trying it other than he didn't want to
go to a better prison cell
huh What stopped him
what was the thing that stopped
Mike Pence
from crowning Donald Trump King at the
certification huh what was it
there wasn't there wasn't a a band of
people that stopped him from doing it
Democrats weren't storming the capital
to stop him from doing it
Mike Pence stopped short of breaking the
[__] long
okay
Law and Order
Law and Order put Mike Pence in a spot
where he had to choose
not to break the law
and what I'm asking
of Glenn
is to not do what Maga did about the the
Pence thing do you remember this I mean
all over the [__] internet they were
like oh Mike Pence can just choose it
Donald Trump's the president
they kept doing that [__] over and over
and it's it sounded dumb it was dumb it
wasn't a thing
it never happened before but it was a
possibility that he could have tried it
right
and what happened
what happened on that day
proud boys Oath Keepers
a bunch of mindless delusional Maga
supporters Trump supporters
drove to an outrage because they were
disappointed that what they were told
was supposed to happen didn't happen
yeah
that's what drove them to the Capitol
that day you've seen the video I mean I
could show it to you
of these insurrections saying Mike Pence
he's he turned on us hang my pants hang
my Pence they [__] called to hang him
the vice president of the United States
because he didn't do what Donald Trump
wanted him to do and what Maga and the
Maga supporters and the proud boys and
The Oath Keepers and on and on it goes
wanted him to do and they were told that
he would do
they were told he was gonna do it even
Donald Trump said he was gonna do it I
know Mike's oh we trust Mike Mike's
going to do what we need him to do
so if you're counting on listen to me if
you're counting on any Democratic
Secretary of State
to cross the line that they're not sure
now it's not criminal but it's still
rather it's legal or not
whether they're going to cross a line as
a duly elected official
to try to keep the confidence of their
constituency the people who [__]
voted for them
to use unilateral power
against a candidate I don't care who the
[__] it is
and if you're if your decision is that
I'm going to be disappointed because
Glenn said it should happen and it can't
happen oh and there's a couple
secretaries of States out there that
eluded that it could happen
foreign
welcome to your Mike Pence moment that's
all I'm saying
that's all I'm saying
and I know it doesn't feel good for me
to say it that way probably
folks we cannot get
ass deep in delusion
in disinformation in [__] that is not
going to happen folks judge Cannon was
supposed to recuse herself do you
remember that oh my God she was gonna
recuse herself nope didn't happen
oh man there's gonna be cameras in the
federal courtroom didn't happen
up this week this week hey this week
right now it's happening right now
online right now as we speak chetkin
chutkin is going to jail Trump for
posting on true social because Jack
Smith and the prosecutors pointed it out
to check in oh my God guess what you're
gonna be disappointed she's not gonna do
[__] about [__]
she's not
and you're gonna be mad at judge
checking just like yesterday
we had justice of 22 years sentencing
tario but you're still pissed off at
Kelly because he didn't give him the
full 33 years folks in a federal
courtroom under a magistrate that
sentences
convicted
convicted Federal uh uh defendants
they never give them the full guideline
Almost Never
yesterday what I was saying about March
4th that J that date that chetkin has
set for Donald Trump's trial almost
never in the history of ever when a
federal
trial goes to a date it's never the
first time
folks it's it's just not
why would it be this time just like a
vice president cannot overthrow the
government during the certification it's
not a thing that happens
there's not going to be a secretary of
state that is going to go out on a limb
to 14 someone when they don't have the
ability or they don't know if they have
we don't know if they have the ability
it hasn't been challenged in court
but people out there saying who are
smart saying that they can it hurts our
democracy
and the reason why it hurts our
democracy is not because Glenn is an
enemy of the democracy
it's because he's promoting
authoritarianism
that's what that is you're using
authoritarianism you're using unilateral
power
that you don't know if you have or not
like Mike Pence did not know if he had
or not
it's it's almost the same thing
it's not exactly but it's close if you
think about it long enough
that's all I'm asking you to do
is to think about these things
think about these things in the context
of our institutions of democracy and our
principles and our foundation that we
have that's the most important thing
that is the most I know we mock Trump I
know we mock Marjorie Taylor green it's
fun and that's actually the best part of
my job sometimes here on the Tony
Michaels podcast but the thing is this
is that that
is what pushes and drives a message and
narrative
when you're when you're asking a
secretary of state
to do something that you don't know if
it is possible or not just like when
Donald Trump asked Mike Pence to do what
we know is not [__] possible or
constitutional now
I mean that that thing has been smoked
out
this idea that the vice president could
just overthrow the government to
whomever they want has been smoked out
it is now official nope that is not a
thing
now is there going to be a secretary of
state that's brave enough to try it I
doubt it
I doubt it
and you can doubt me like you can doubt
me all you want
you can doubt me on on the the judge
Cannon recusing herself you can doubt me
on the March 4th date you can doubt me
on the cameras in the courtrooms in the
Federal courtrooms
you can doubt me if he's gonna go to
trial next year if he's going to go to
trial in the Georgia case which I don't
believe he's going to do just doubt me
just just do it but do it do it in a way
that promotes your democracy that's all
I ask that's it that's all I ask
and I'm so happy that you guys yesterday
were having conversations in the chat do
you know how excited that gets me
that some of you have the fire in you
that is that's beautiful that is what
this is about
that's what the whole thing is about
is to get to a place where our [__]
makes sense again
it doesn't make any [__] sense
yesterday
a domestic terrorist was [__]
sentenced to 22 years because the former
president of the United States asked him
to help him overturn the government
and this guy took the leader of this
group this terrorist group
him and his terrorists his terrorist
members
went at the behest of the president of
the United he said on stage during the
bait proud boys stand back and stand by
and at his orders Enrique Taria
yesterday received 22 years in prison
because they helped him with his plot to
overthrow the government
we are not in normal times folks
this is not getting [__] back to normal
anytime soon or quick
so we have to stay vigilant against
misinformation
and [__] that just is not [__] gonna
happen
it's okay that there's a March 4th date
for Trump's trial in DC that's okay it's
okay to say that's the date
he could go to trial but it's not okay
to have the expectation if he doesn't
that our democracy is in peril
it's not checking's job to save
democracy it is her job to control her
courtroom
that is her job
is to preside over her courtroom
and I am I am here to tell you that
there is no better
there is no better person
to preside over that courtroom in that
case then chetkin I'll tell you I
believe because of how she is going to
handle this rather she pisses off you or
she pisses off manga
judge chutkin
is probably going to see a time in her
life that is she going that she will be
on the Supreme Court
and this will be one of the highlights
of her career
not just that she tried this case
but that she did so well
for justice for the country
for our Law and Order
here in our nation
Canon down in Florida [__] she won't
even come close to ever being a
consideration for a Supreme Court
Justice unless
we don't stay vigilant
and we elect more fascists oh my God a
fascist would put her on the Supreme
Court bam quick passing in a hurry
so that's all I ask that's all I ask
is yeah is it possible sure anything's
possible isn't it really isn't anything
possible
anything really I mean [__] Trump could
go to trial next year can end up in
prison he could still be on the ballot
he could still be the nominee the
Republicans would make him the nominee
even if he's in the jail cell hell they
said he would
yeah they said they were [__] yeah they
put him ah yeah sure no why not
it's a good idea isn't it
I'm not here to be correct I'm not here
to tell the future I mean you can doubt
me if you want
but I'm not here to tell the future
but I what I am here to do is give me
the cold hard rule raw [__] truth
whether you like it or not
that's what I'm here to do
now I'm here to do it standing on the
institution of democracy as a foundation
no matter who is saying what
what their background what their
expertise they say it is I don't give a
[__]
and I'm not gonna stop speaking out the
way that I'll speak out against whoever
needs to be stuck at spoke out against
spuck out yeah get the [__] out
and again I I like Glenn Glenn knows
what he's talking about except for when
he says things that are just not
possible
and it's it again I hate to say it and I
I know you're gonna be really mad at me
when I say this but what he was saying
about the 14th that's misinformation
he's misleading you with facts
little crumbs of facts he's misleading
yeah the 14th yeah sure does it not say
that you can't as a secretary of state
sure it says that
14 section three people were typing it
on all all the all day yesterday in the
chat and I appreciate you
I appreciate you
challenging me challenging each other
do you know who doesn't do that
fascists they don't challenge each other
at all oh my God any kind of descent
on the side of fascism [__] I mean we
know what happens in history when you
descend from fascism right
not here though
I welcome to sin I welcome trolls I mean
unless you're just an absolute [__]
[__] and then we'll you know show
you to the door and use your head to
open it
but that's it
we just we just got to get back to a
place to where we're we're arguing over
stuff like well what is the absolute the
absolute maximum that I that a doctor's
copay should be can you imagine if I had
to do 30 minutes listen to me do you
know how excited I would be to get to a
place in this country where I had to do
a 30 minute rant
on why it is so important that a
doctor's co-pay
is x amount instead of x amount or if
the the minimum wage is this amount
instead of that amount do you know how
excited I'm gonna be that we're back to
normal times where we can debate
actually things that [__] matter but
we can't right now
there are people trying to destroy our
possibility of doing that thing
they don't want us to have the ability
to [__] hash out between us and the
elections of what the minimum wage
should be how much health care a person
should get rather a per rather a person
has the ability to get health care in
their Community or not because hospitals
are leaving rather we should fund
schools and libraries and feed people
you know and there's a problem with
homelessness there's all kinds of [__]
but folks they want to take your ability
away to do any of that
they want to take all your Liberty away
to do that not just your lifestyle they
want to take the entire [__] country
away from us
when they say they want to go back to
the good old days they don't mean the
1950s
you think that's what they mean the
1950s [__] no
they mean long past that and they mean
in a different place than this country
they want fascism they want rule they
want authoritarianism
and we should not bring ourselves to use
authoritarianism to try to save our
democracy what we should do is use the
institution of democracy
to advance it
to stomp out fascism
in our nation
to kill the narrative
of hate
and it's a long hard fight like you're
gonna have to punch a lot of Nazis in
the meantime
hypothetically theoretically speaking
not literally I mean maybe
I don't know you might be walking around
out one day and you know have to swing I
don't know
but I'm just I just want you to stay
vigilant
against disengagement
against discouragement
that's the important part because if we
get discouraged the pro-democracy
Coalition gets discouraged
we will lose our energy
and if we lose our energy we can lose
our democracy
and every little bit is going to count
all of it every single last bit of it
so consider that
consider that when I say what I say you
can disagree with me do it please
speak out to tweet at me tweet at me you
[__] when I say something you
don't like challenge me
be mad
have that outrage
point that outrage towards saving our
democracy that's what I ask of you
because you're the best audience in the
world you truly are
you truly are no matter how mad at me
you are no matter how much you disagree
I don't care you're the best audience
and the reason why is because you guys
engage
and that is the important part that's
the most important thing that you engage
and you pay attention
and you try to think about the issues
and what is being told to you
the best attribute of our democracy
it'll Advance equality Equity diversity
and it'll make this a better Nation
it'll make it the best country on Earth
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back Mark
seconds this
is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
sticking around through the break you're
going to want to stick around to the
whole show we get some announcements
today at the top of the hour when Yates
Sanchez
we're gonna have the
some expansion
announcements of how we're going to
expand the show I know I said that
yesterday kind of loaded it yesterday
people like what's happening what's
gonna happen what's going on we're gonna
let you know today
we're gonna let you know today uh
Stephanie says here on YouTube says Tony
will voters get discouraged or
complacent in what happens in the next
few months I mean it is a possibility
that's always a possibility
and they can get discouraged if I mean
the bar is set to a possible thing that
isn't really possible
I mean again this week I believe this
week the next uh round of stuff that I'm
gonna have to fight back against the
uh the people on the left yelling and
screaming something that isn't going to
happen is Czech can jail in Trump
because he's posting on true social
folks it's just it I
I mean you you can doubt me on it
you're gonna be disappointed if you
think that chutkin is somehow gonna jail
Trump because he's posting on true
social
I know I know but he's saying this Tony
but he's saying that and that that
sounds I mean that's you know it sounds
like and she said she said oh she said
the last time
foreign
let it play out then all right fine and
you know that I'll admit that I'm wrong
when I'm wrong right
when I'm way off I mean there's a damn
uh if you go to the Discord and they got
a a channel going in the Discord server
and it's called doubt me
and like I even got merch that says
doubt me look at this uh let me see it
here it is here's the doubt me merch
we got doubt me merch
you can go to store.d Tony michaels.com
and get doubt me merge if you want
but there's a there's a section now
on the Discord server and you should go
join the Discord server let me let me
give you the link to that uh because the
chat over there is uh hey they're crazy
over there if you want to get in on the
party holy moly
you think there's and there's like I
mean there's almost nothing you can say
I mean Discord is like off the chain
right you know that right
like the only rules on Discord are the
rules that we make not the [__] em fam
that's the only rules it's the rules
that the [__] fan makes
they got a channel over there called
doubt me and they're keeping track of
um stuff that I say
predictions that I make
it's not predictions really honestly
they're not predictions I mean the
shit's gonna either go one way or the
other right
and I'm not I'm not I'm not you know
making huge predictions of
like exactly of exact things I'm just
taking something that's either gonna be
a yay or a nay and just
just calling it Black or White like yeah
that's not gonna happen or it sounds
like that's gonna happen
it's not that difficult
it's not that hard to see to be quite
honest small rat said forecast yeah it's
gonna be sunny
it's gonna be sunny in our democracy
I'm very optimistic do you remember last
year during 2022 during the midterms oh
man all the polls were saying all the
polls and the polls this and the polls
that and I was like [__] them polls
those polls don't know what the [__]
they're talking about
there is no gonna be no red wave and
there wasn't
there wasn't we were so [__] close to
what I thought was gonna happen I really
thought that the Democrats I thought
they were going to eke it out with like
one seat
it it looked like it it looked like they
could do it now they didn't
Lauren bobert won her Race by like 300
[__] votes some other Republicans
barely won
uh George Santos lied to his
constituency
about who he was what his name was even
to get to you know to just get those few
seats so Kevin McCarthy could pretend to
be Speaker of the House
when it's actually Donald Trump as the
Speaker of the House
but there was no red wave
I said there was it for months and
months and months and months and months
not like two days into uh up to the lead
up to the election I said it for months
because the media is like oh man it sure
does look like there's going to be a red
wave it looks like Republicans are
really going to take over the house and
the Senate oh my God these polls polls
polls and polls they were all [__]
just like the polls right now that show
that Biden and Trump are neck and neck
get the [__] out of here with that
[__] that's the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard in my life
give me a break
you're telling me a poll organization
that Trump has given money to paid
travel expenses for we're supposed to
take that seriously
are you kidding me get the [__] out of
here
do you do you have any idea how bad
these polls are that you that the media
is touting and showing you they're
[__] horrible they're not even close
the last election where polls were even
remotely close to what happened was
2016.
and the popular vote that was really the
last time that the polls were anywhere
close to being correct
that's the only reason that's the only
reason why
that's the only reason why
I
I say just just doubt me
I don't go off the [__] polls
I go off what feels like
logical and reason
I think I think you have a good a good
pulse of what average Americans want
your your average Americans
you're not elitist
you're not the one percent
you're not Silver Spoons you're just not
you have you have a good good way about
you in this audience
regardless if we disagree sometimes
that's that's not that's not the biggest
deal
um yeah someone's requesting um
someone's pointing out someone's
requesting a black [__] hat oh
Gracie's you're rolling your eyes
so now Tony is a doubt Merchant
no I'm saying doubt me
I just I'm not I'm not promoting you to
doubt me I'm just saying don't
use your use use what common sense you
got
don't listen to what the TV tells you is
all I'm saying
that you know you know you know what the
one thing the the cable news networks
that I'm more disappointed in and then
anything is their only goal is to keep
you watching yeah everyone's saying
black hats they want black [__] pants
you want black [__] ants see this is
the red one I'll get you some black ones
I think there is a black one there is a
black one hang on a second here
Brian I'll get back to the media in a
second
in one second there is you go to hats
not me Tony michaels.com
or you go to the Tony michaels.com and
you just hit the hat store link
there's black [__] hats I promise you
watch this here we go here we go here we
go here's the [__] hat store
let me show you here if I can get it
there's a red one there's a there's a
pink one there's there's a black one
there's a beanie but look if you go in
this one the pink one here you just
click in there look there's a black one
you can get a black one
black white red pink
there's a black one right there there's
blood black vocal mans I mean it's not
the it's not the uh the fitted hat like
this one it's not the fitted hat like
this one
well let me see wait a second I I don't
know I don't know if there's a there's
the availability to do a
yeah there is okay here here's here's
the fitted hat
here you go
there's a black [__] hat right there
boom
there it is black fitted hat
there it is black hat you can get a
black hat
black [__] ants
they're there they exist
um
someone's auctioning them off in in the
Discord jet
[Laughter]
oh my God
the Discord chat I'm telling you it's
crazy over there um yeah yeah you can
get him you can get a black [__] man
let's see
let me go back to the I'll go back to
the Tony michaels.com I'll show you how
to get to it
I'll show you I'll show you it's here
there you go so uh first thing you're
going to want to do when you go to the
Tony michaels.com is hit subscribe at
the top of the page you're not going to
want to forget to subscribe because I
send you notifications when anything
changes like if we were to get new merch
I could send you an email saying hey we
got that merch you guys wanted
um and you go down to official merch the
[__] em hats right here in the middle
[__] em hats right there just click on
[__] match right there the one in the
middle and you can go and you can get
you a black one or a blue one or a red
one or pink one whatever you want
whatever you want over there on the Tony
michaels.com as far as the [__] hats
there you go uh we're gonna have some
more merch uh coming soon too we're
we've got some stuff in the works
um that is one announcement that's not
the whole announcement for the expansion
we got way bigger news than that
um but but yes you you we are going to
have some new merch soon you know what
why I got the page up I might as well
show you this again you can subscribe
here at the top you should subscribe it
doesn't cost you anything I don't like
sell your email or anything of that I
just notify you when something changes
so I just I just click and say notify
everyone on the list that this has
changed and then they send you an email
of what has changed the main thing I do
is like every day that we have a show
I send you the new link uh for the show
so you get the new the new link for the
show every morning before the show
starts that way you get the notification
there
because honestly I'm I'm sick of posting
on Twitter
oh social media
um you can buy me a shot today is today
is karaoke day for me like in real life
karaoke I got a karaoke every Wednesday
we're gonna go to karaoke tonight and I
do Jager shots you know tomorrow morning
I'll probably be hungover from Jaeger
shots so if you want to buy me a Jager
shot uh tonight go ahead and uh you can
buy me a shot right there you know what
I'm maybe I'll do tonight if you buy me
a shot I'll take a video and I'll post a
video thanking you guys if you buy me a
shot so you know that I actually bought
a Sean
so the other day I was telling my wife
about the new shot thing and that you
guys loved it I was like ah they love
they love this buying Tony a shot thing
I was like it's it's really it's really
cool
and um because I know I A lot of times
people have been saying in the chat we
want to buy you a shot we want to buy
you a shot or we want to do a shot with
you something along those lines right
and I was like you know that's that's a
good idea we could do that yeah it's
kind of a joke because I mean some of
the money will go but she was like do
they really think you're going to take
that many shots
I was like I don't think they think I'm
gonna take that many I mean I could
Jesus Christ can you imagine how great
this show would be if I took that many
Jager shots Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ
oh man the other thing you can do over
on the Tony michaels.com is you can send
in a venmo super chat it's this link
right here with the V the venmo uh you
can go to the vimo Super Chat and you
send me a message and you can you can
say hey thanks Tony or you can ask a
question or you can challenge me like um
Anna did yesterday Anna did yesterday
which is fine which is fine challenge me
like that
you can also find the patreon link there
as well as well and if you want to join
the Discord just roll on down the
Discord servers right here under podcast
link it's right here Discord server now
so go check out the Tony michaels.com
subscribe over there now you can go
another thing that you're going to want
to do is go follow Gabe's YouTube
channel right here
follow Gabe's YouTube channel don't
forget to do that help Gabe Sanchez out
over there so go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com subscribe there for all
your updates you know I think I'm gonna
do too
um since you're subscribed over there
because you know we have an audio
version
of the podcast
and we get a lot of people downloaded
but man we could use uh a boost in the
rankings
so the more downloads we get even if you
listen to the show because I know I
think there's a way that you can sit on
your phone where it downloads every
episode automatically or something
and it gives us it gives us it puts us
in the rankings is the main thing so it
helps us with the rankings
um so if you if you want I can if you
guys want I can send I can send a
notification when the actual audio
uh version releases and just send you
that link and then you guys can go and
and download it on your favorite
directory Apple Spotify Google wherever
you want we can do that we can send an
update for that just let me know if you
want an update
on the audio version as well to remind
you
I don't want to send too many
I think I can send like I think they
allow me to send three a day or
something like that
on linktree because it's just a link
tree the Tony michaels.com is just a
link tree I just have the Tony
michaels.com forward to it so it's easy
so I don't have to be like link tree
slash D20 mic but it's just the link
tree
but they allow me to send I think three
notifications
to this to the people who are subscribed
every day so I can't send you more than
three
a day I think within like a 24 hour
period
but I send you the show and I'll send
you the audio if you want and then any
anything else that changes that'll be
like the third one if we have something
that changes but you guys let me know if
it's too much if it's not enough if you
want more updates on the subscribers
because I'm not gonna sell your email or
anything like that it's just to send you
guys the updates that's all it's for
that is all it is for and it's all it's
for and if you really want to stay up to
date again go join the Discord this is
the [__] em fam over there this is
getting bigger and bigger over there and
I know I've been talking a lot about it
and people you know I've been bragging
about it and people on the Discord love
when I talk about the Discord because
they're over there right
but you guys really should if you don't
have the Discord app and if and if
you're scared about not being able to
figure it out don't it's not that hard
it really isn't the other thing too if
you're not tech savvy it's okay they've
like Mighty librarian over there she's
like the Discord manager now it's like
she's she's building that whole thing
out it's it's crazy she's got directions
in each room what to do there's a whole
guide that you can that you can see
um to show you how Discord works just
make sure when you go join the Discord
let me put that link in the chat one
more time when you go join the Discord
and again the links down below you go to
the Tony michaels.com and check it out
there but here's the thing
um when you go in verify so then they
know you're a human because sometimes
like Bots will go over
a storm Virgil says unofficial manager
unofficial
okay try challenging the local librarian
over there try try [__] up in the
Discord and with the librarian on staff
it's storm Virgil yeah they have fun
over there storm Virgil's over there all
the time money librarian Skips a
moderator over there skip helps us with
the clips on the YouTube channel all the
clips that you've been seeing that have
been released uh this morning we had
some of the Boston Brian he cut some
clips of the Boston Brian episode it's
really great so go to the YouTube
channel make sure you subscribe there uh
so you'll get those notifications on
YouTube and hit the Bell notification
because you're going to want to see
these clips and because he takes the
best parts of the episode and puts him
in like a 30 40 50 second clip it's
great uh you did the one of uh Nick
Fuentes is that one is that one live yet
I don't know if that one's live yet but
he didn't want to Nick Fuentes where
Boston Brian called him based
because Nick went just like everyone
hates me and I'm like hey man you told
the truth and that was hilarious all
right so it was a great moment so he
takes great yes he skips his uh the the
the Beast the Nick Fuentes based Boston
Brian clip is on YouTube it's it's great
go watch that one
um but but skip is so good at finding
like those little moments during the
show because I do the show two hours I
don't remember every little thing but uh
but he does a great job so give skip
credit over there um when you go over to
the Discord and visit his YouTube
channel too uh you got to see some of
the stuff that skit does with his guitar
and he plays guitar and stuff in the
Discord everyone's like streaming over
there if you're into gaming if you like
food they have a food channel uh they've
got they've got like a stuff you made
Channel there's picture Channel there's
a meme Channel if you're looking for
political means god damn there's just
mountains mountains of political means
already in the Discord so if you're
looking for like a great meme list
there's the meme Channel over there so
go go over to the Discord really
honestly and don't don't be uh too
intimidated by it it's not that hard
once you get going it's it's almost
easier than any other social media I was
kind of intimidated at first but um the
way the way that it's organized in there
and the way the community helps you out
in there and there's always someone
around almost 24 hours a day that can
guide you to where exactly where you
need to be
um and and what you want to see and once
you get the hang of it it's it's perfect
it's great
um just make sure to have your mic on
mute if you go into like one of the
there was one day I went into I I think
they were streaming something
like a John Oliver episode or something
is that what they were streaming
something and I had my live mic open I
may have been saying stuff or something
that I shouldn't have been or something
I don't know
uh so go go over to the Discord uh and
join the [__] fam over there I'm
telling you it's it's great it's great
community that they're building over
there it is it is for the podcast but
folks it is the [__] fam over there
it's not it's not just all about me it
really isn't they talk about all kinds
of politics they have discussions in
certain rooms about certain topics
um and and and again the community over
there is is more than happy to show you
around and teach you how to use it and
and utilize it
um and really honestly uh all the
directions in the room that the money
librarian give her props and skip over
there he's done a great job at the clips
and being a moderator over there on
Discord so go join the Discord it's
where the Discord never stops um you
know I like to joke around and say that
they need Jesus and they really do uh
some of the some of the some of the
people on during the live chat I have it
up right now and I watch it oh my God
it's just like a it's just like a
pinball machine of memes and gifts
and all the comments because it's
different than the YouTube channel like
the YouTube chat you can't put in an
image or like a gif or anything
you can't and you can't you know you
can't do that over here on YouTube you
can do it over there though and they do
like I'll say like right now I said they
need Jesus and oh my God it's Jesus
memes
like right now that's all that's popping
up as Jesus means
so
get in over on the Discord chat it's
great it's great and I love every single
one of you again yesterday A lot of
people are mad at me for what I was
saying but I I was saying it because
I'm trying to be authentic I don't I
don't want to be something different on
the show and you know if you talk to
people who talk to me personally like on
the phone you'll know that this is me
this is me I rant to people I was
talking to Boston Brian on the phone the
other day before the show that he came
on that's what he's trying to see he's
like oh my god I didn't even think of it
I had the day off we were talking he was
trying to figure out when he's gonna
Jesus Sanchez oh my God when he was
when he was going to when he was going
to come on the show and he's like that
day was the perfect day and we didn't
even realize it
but he was talking on the phone and he's
like man you're the same you like rant
on the phone the same way and I was
telling him I was like no this is a
secret that I have
this is a secret that I have and I'll
I'll give you the audience the secret
when I'm sitting here talking to you
guys sometimes I pretend I'm talking to
a friend on the phone right you ever
talk to a friend on the phone that you
agree with and you two are like yelling
and screaming but you're not yelling
screaming at each other you're just
cathartically yelling because you got to
get it out you got to get that release
right
[__] these [__] fascists right
it's how you feel right you want to
[__] just [__] why in the
[__] can't we just get to a place where
Maga is smarter than what they are and
they stop believing the [__] right
like you feel that way right oh [__]
why can't we just lock these
[__] who try to overthrow our
government up right yeah I I feel a rage
I feel the anger
because you just want to move on right
you just want to move on to better
[__] [__] to to more important things
than trying to have to fend off people
who don't love our country they [__]
hate our country
these scumbags like Enrique tario and
and and and Stuart Rhodes and Donald
Trump they don't they hate our country
they hate it
Charlie Kirk Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh Sean
Hannity Tucker Carlson Elon Musk all the
in-cell army that they have they [__]
hate our country they [__] hate it
that's why they're so mad that's why
they want to have all the culture Awards
because they hate our country they hate
diversity they hate [__] Equity they
hate Liberty they hate Freedom they hate
people having rights that aren't white
and men they [__] hate it
and it pisses you off right you [__]
just oh [__] why can't we get in a place
where people understand that diversity
and Equity is good democracy is good
progression is good
it's not all about [__] white men
controlling everything right if we just
get past that white Christian
nationalism stuff you know that that
[__] you feel and you're sitting on the
phone talking to your friend who agrees
with all of that and you're just yelling
right yeah you're pissed but you're not
really pissed at each other you're just
pissed with them with them right you're
pissed with them
you're just you're you're trying to use
your [__] cathartic release for each
other because you're so pissed and you
can't really go say it at work
or you can't go to your church and say
this [__] right
you can't you can't I mean you could
you could just like I said yeah sure
secretary could State could try the 14th
and uh probably not a good idea
Mike Pence could try to overthrow the
government probably not a good idea
it's not a good idea to go into church
and talk like I do on the show probably
not a good idea I mean you could do it
it's not a good idea but you know that
feeling that you get oh you're [__]
pissed
stay pissed
point that pissed off strategic outrage
in a certain direction but here's what I
told Brian here's the secret I know I
told you I'd tell you a secret here's
the secret
I pretend sometimes when I'm doing the
show especially the first 30 minutes
like right now I'm pretending I'm
talking to you on the phone
this is what I do
pretend like I'm talking to you on the
phone
I've said this before and a lot of
people called me uh the rushland ball
the left
which I guess it's probably appropriate
I don't know I don't know if I'm
rushland bar if it's something else but
he's probably the closest thing to
political commentary that you can
compare to me compare me to on the right
if that makes sense
but here's the thing
Rush Limbaugh was a was a crazy good
talent
now he used that talent for evil [__]
vile [__]
to promote fascism and push this country
towards a a position that we're in now
to to to to stoke the cult
to form the cult to find the cult leader
he did that in this country
almost almost all by himself now he
didn't carry the whole thing on his back
but his talent set the tone for that
kind of garbage in our country that kind
of narrative in our country because
everyone wanted to copycat him right
everyone wanted to copycat him Glenn
Beck Sean Hannity
Mark Levin
Savage Michael Savage all of them Tucker
Carlson
Ben Shapiro Now Matt Walsh they all
wanted to emulate him
and copy him they just didn't have the
exact talent that He had
I mean there's so many parallels between
me and Rush we're both from rural
Missouri
we're both College dropouts we both have
have run-ins with the law
I mean I've never been arrested for
doing drugs
Rush was
but I I partake
and I'm not scared to say it like Rush
would always talk about how you'd smoke
cigars and his form and smoke cigarettes
is formerly nicotine's nicotine stain
fingers his his
downfalls he did not hide
but there's one thing that Rush did
there's one thing that he did well and
that was the [__] worst thing because
of the vile trash that he pumped into
people's minds the propaganda the
[__] the lies that he was able to
convince people of
when you listen to him on the radio it
felt like he was talking to you
it's what I felt like
it felt like that he was talking to you
not not to a broad audience or you know
just trying to hawk or Griff [__] right
he was talking to you
and it pissed me off like I'd be [__]
and you can imagine I'd be yelling at
the radio you [__] you son of a
[__] you [__] lying piece of trash I
mean that's you know like I do every day
here I'd be yelling at the radio at rush
but I'm telling you
I'm telling you and I I know a lot of
people don't believe me they don't I've
had them tell me now Tony if you just if
you just do this or you just do that
you know you'll have a bigger audience
you get more clicks you get more views
you know this and that and I'm like I
don't give a [__] about that that's that
I don't give a [__] about how many
clicks
I don't care about how many [__]
followers I have on [__] Twitter I
gave that [__] up long ago to worry
about that [__]
I really don't give a [__] about that
all I want is people to listen to the
show
I don't care if they acknowledge it or
not I don't care if they're here to hate
watch if they hear here to love me I or
love to hate me I don't give a [__]
I want to promote a message I want to
set a narrative
and I believe that the model that the
right uses it works
it works here's a big secret that the
left doesn't know it [__] works
why do you think I'm the best kept
secret in politics because the left is
terrified of me
oh [__] yeah they're [__] scared of
me
I'm not saying they're trying to silence
me I'm not playing victim here
but they definitely don't want it out in
the open
that there's some there's some kind of
alternative to the MPR David packman tyt
MSNBC
Progressive SMX or S XM radio [__]
it's boring
they don't want you to know that there's
a rock and roll tattooed alternative
that's the way it feels right the show
people have said that over on Discord
it's like the rock and roll tattooed
version of the left
right I mean hell the theme music
everyone's like oh man this is the best
[__] theme music ever well where do
you think that inspiration came from
the right that's what the right does
that's what they do because it's not
about like in media and that's one thing
again the left does horribly they're bad
at it they're just [__] horrible at
it
all of them really I mean there's not
there's a few of them like Hal's really
good at it I'll admit it Hal's really
good at this right he's a really good
he's a really good example of a of a
kept secret
how
here's the thing and yeah we welcome the
sparklers here that's why the sparklers
love coming here
because Hal doesn't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] now his style is a little
different than mine
I'll admit it and this is more like a
radio show this is more like a stream
you know what I mean it's just different
there's nothing wrong with it
how's one of the better ones is what I'm
saying
but here's the thing here's the thing
that the lamp is horrible at is it's not
about what you say first they always
like oh no you gotta have the data and
you gotta have the facts and you gotta
have a whole stack of it you got to show
it to them
no you don't
no you know people are smart enough they
don't need they don't need a bunch of a
bunch of [__] data to back up their
Common Sense what they know is true
they don't need that [__] they don't
need they don't need a bunch of data
showing that most Americans don't want
to go broke because of a medical bill
I mean are there anyone is there anyone
clamoring out there to go broke because
of a medical bill
it's like you know what my life would be
much better if I could just receive an
an a really eighty thousand dollar bill
you know to sideswipe me in my mailbox
because I had a health condition a
couple months ago that would be great if
we could work that out no they're not
doing that
no one wants to be uneducated in this
country they don't they want to get an
education I mean on the right they they
call it and they call it education it's
indoctrination but they want it right
there are hard things to know you don't
need a bunch of polls to know that
you don't need a bunch of polls to know
that Donald Trump is not popular
people do not like that [__]
they don't like him
it's not hard to know that you just go
out I live in Trump country and most
people are like yeah I don't like that
[__] they'd vote for him but
they're like I don't like that
[__]
it's true
it's the truth there's very few people
still riding around in Trump country
with Trump Flags it's very rare you see
one you saw him in 20 you know 2016 2017
and in 2020 they kind of came back you
don't see them anymore
you don't really see a lot of a few of
them here and there not really even in
Trump country no
they're not that excited
they want they want you to believe that
the Trump supporters are excited about
it but it's all [__] it's all
[__] you don't need that kind of
thing
that's what the left media doesn't
understand it's about how you say it
first
it's about how you say it it's about how
you keep people
this audience stays here from the very
beginning from the elevator music tell
them head ass speaking I mean there's
people who know what that means head ass
speaking
who why the [__] would anyone stick
around for that
but you do
and the reason why is because of how I
present
politics how I present it and that's
important
that's important that's important work
that we are doing and we're doing it
together I know it feels like it's just
me yelling and screaming but I would be
nothing without you nothing
nothing
because you guys listen
like yesterday when you were mad at me
some of you were mad some of you agreed
with me some of you were mad at me but
you were listening you stayed you stayed
even though you're mad at me
stayed why did you stay
there's a reason
and it's designed that way but it's
supposed to be that's what national
narrative and National messaging is
supposed to be about
that's what it's supposed to be is to
drive that message for democracy
to drive it in that direction that's
what rush was doing he was driving in
the opposite direction though
that's what he was doing he's driving in
the opposite direction we're trying to
pull it back we're trying to you know
make up for all that time that the right
was good at it
and still good at they're still they're
still phenomenal at this they're [__]
fantastic at propaganda oh and that's a
word that left hates you can't say that
word oh you can't say propaganda
[__] how do you think we're gonna
fight bad propaganda how do you think
we're gonna fight it what do you think
we're gonna do stand around and quote a
bunch of polls that are a bunch of
[__] that are a bunch of propaganda
themselves come on man come on get with
the game you don't win you don't win a
boxing match by standing outside the
ring
that ain't how you win in boxing I mean
if you want to do the boxing reference
whatever whatever analogy you want to
make
the boxing analogy works though you're
not gonna win a boxing match standing
outside the ring you got to get inside
the ring you gotta throw some [__]
punches you gotta put on the gloves like
they got on
you gotta walk around really [__]
swing at him give him some good Heat
you know
even if you don't knock them out
you gotta go all those rounds with them
to the very end
and hopefully hopefully at the very end
the judges Choose You
but that's what you gotta do you gotta
get in the fight and you guys are in the
fight
and I think Gabe Sanchez is going to be
with us here really soon so let's do
this let's go to a break when we come
back
Gabe Sanchez should be joining us we'll
see you don't go anywhere don't touch
that dial
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
democracy propaganda
maybe that's what we should do we're the
home I think I've said it before they
were the home of the pro-democracy
propaganda
hey Sanchez is going to join us in just
a minute we got big announcements for
you stick around don't go anywhere
you're not going to want to leave don't
go anywhere don't get anywhere just
because you're mad at me
you're gonna like what Gabe Sanchez has
to say I'm dead serious you're gonna
love this
you're gonna love these this new
expansion that we're gonna do
it's gonna be great
um
yeah so someone's asking about the uh
the bias shot on YouTube
uh some people are wanting to buy a shot
so all that is is just like a tip jar on
linktree so you just go to link tree
just go to the tonymichaels.com that's
all you got to do is just go to the
attorney michaels.com let me show you
where it's at let's see if we got any
here Let's see we got any shots we'll
probably have some tonight definitely
have some tonight
oh Gary Gary sent a shot thanks Gary
I'll take that one tonight Gary
and it looks like um
looks like Charles sent a shot too
here's how you do it you just go to the
Tony michaels.com make sure you hit the
Subscribe button at the very top don't
forget to subscribe first you're not
going to want to miss a thing any of the
updates again I'm not going to email you
like a thousand times a day just gonna
email you like the Show links and that
sort of thing if you don't want that you
know that's cool
but if you want the notifications you
should subscribe but see this one that's
like bouncing around there see how it's
bouncing around that's by Tony a shot
you just go to that one you know what
and here's what I'll do right now as we
speak I'll put that one at the top of
the page
so it's at the very top
there we go
Ariel so say look look now let me
refresh this all right
that's how this thing works boom now
it's at the very top CS go to the Tony
michaels.com and here's what I'll do too
I'll make it a priority but I'll make it
pop up
oh no that's not what I want there we go
okay let's make it like that
make it like that like that make it like
that okay so now when you go to the Tony
michaels.com the first thing is going to
pop up is buy Tony a shot and I'll leave
it on there till tomorrow morning I'll
change it back tomorrow morning because
then you know I'll be doing shots all
night long
for the people who is wanting to know
how to buy a shot
in the in the chat there a lot of people
were wanting to buy a shot in the chat
so if you want to if you want to get me
around or a double round and you can go
buy everyone around too on the
on the link tree just go to
thetonymichaels.com buy Tony shots at
the very top it'll pop up automatically
now when you go to whether you're on
your phone or you're on a computer it'll
pop up it's very easy
you just select which one you want to do
um and if you want to give a custom
amount you just go down to the tip jar
and if you want to get on the chat the
vimo chat if you want to be on the show
you can go to the venmo link
and do that as well
oh so I want to show you some video here
let's get to some video
I definitely want to show you guys the
video today as we wait for Gabe Sanchez
and the announcements that we're gonna
have
here we go okay so
um
yesterday Peter Navarro
Enrique tarrio was sentenced yesterday
but there was a lot of [__]
Republican criminals in court yesterday
Peter Navarro was was one of them
apparently is is a trial is starting
this morning but yesterday
I'm in love man I'm in love with this um
this whistle thing and this woman who
stands behind Peter Navarro oh my God
have you seen this we showed the video
the other day where he's trying to take
down her sign and [__] and he's all mad
that she's standing behind him talking
to him watch this [__] from yesterday
this is hilarious and and this this is
almost two minutes this goes on for
almost two minutes but watch watch how
Peter Navarro can't even put two
sentences together
because he is so triggered by this lady
standing behind him watch this is great
with the stand is inside thank you uh
WWE
left
all right if you can't see your sign
here let me back it up a second it says
it says prison boys [__] around find out
tario Tick Tock
I don't know who this is I don't know
who this is but I love her oh my God I
love her this is the exact proper way to
to to deal with these people right
because all Peter Navarro is gonna do is
stand there and just spew a bunch of
[__] lies into the microphone and
try to get the media to promote his
[__] lies and you know what she does
she's like [__] that [__] I'm gonna make
sure he can't even put his thoughts
together
yeah I want to make sure you can't even
put his thoughts together to even even
be able to form lines out of his mouth
but watch what happened watch what he
calls her this is great watch
oh [__]
this is um this is what's wrong with
America here oh yeah yeah that's what's
wrong with America Peter Navarro that
people can protest your ass Oh that's oh
that's what's wrong with America you
know these people talk about either for
freedom and all this [__] and Liberty
but when it comes down to it they don't
they don't want Liberty and freedom for
anyone but themselves and that statement
proves it right there when Peter Navarro
looks at someone protesting him he does
not have to have that press conference
right there on that public sidewalk he
could rent a conference room somewhere
folks he could rent a conference room
somewhere and invite the media to the
conference room and have a private
[__] press conference where it's just
the press and no one else is allowed in
to [__] protest him they'd have to
protest outside but he chooses to do it
on the sidewalk and he hates when
someone
he's [__] protesting him on the
sidewalk
the [__] out of here man this is public
space this is public
since when do you get to tell me huh
since when do you get to tell me what I
can and can't do in public and that what
all those anti-masters used to say even
though they got the [__] word public
[__] up they don't know the that
there's several definitions of it
but here to Peter Navarro is standing on
a public sidewalk where she has just as
much right to stand there and make noise
as he does
this is they don't understand they don't
understand what our country is and
that's why they [__] hate it they
[__] hate it Peter Navarro hates our
country he hates that she is allowed to
stand there and and have a voice and
overtake his voice because his voice as
a white man and and a conservative a
[__] traitor is more important than
her voice
she he kissed my ass
Peter
she's more of a patriot than you'll ever
[__] dream of because she understands
what freedom is read or [__] sign you
piece of [__] but keep going this is
this is great this is one of the best
pieces of [__] content I've seen in a
long time www.defendpeter.com
[Music]
defend
that's hilarious oh my God how [__]
funny is that [__] oh my God so every
time he tries
every time he tries to grip he's like oh
yeah
she just [__] shuts him down with the
whistle
oh my God
after my [__]
anti-fascist antifa heart she is oh my
God
this is how you treat these
[__] especially when they're
trying to do this [__] where they're
trying to lie in front of cameras and
microphones in public on a public
sidewalk get the [__] out of here man
we don't have to put up with your
[__] she doesn't have to put up with
your [__] now watch
it gets better I know you don't think it
will but it gets better man cut it out
man let the man talk man let the man
talk let him talk man
he has every right to talk come on come
on
[Applause]
he can talk he can talk why can't he
talk why can't he talk is he so
distracted by the way is he so scared of
a whistle is he so scared of a woman
holding a sign since when did white
powerful men the manly masculine men be
so scared of a woman with a whistle and
a sign huh I thought part Peter Navarro
was much more manly than that that's
because it's all [__] all that
narrative and all that [__] it's all
[__] they're [__] weak cowards
every last one of them that's what
fascism is
fascism fascism Foundation is built on
cowardice
they cower away from what is true and
this woman doesn't give a [__] not one
[__] she does not back down she does not
cower from this piece of [__] traitor
Peter Navarro watch this
play this
way
because this is just wrong I'm trying to
speak about serious
constitutionalization
the serious constitutional additional
issue uh Gabe Sanchez is that Peter
Navarro tried to overturn our government
that's the serious constitutional issue
yeah that's that's there's another
Constitution issue he he has held in
contempt of congress because he wouldn't
apply to a lawful subpoena those are
constitutional issues well you gotta
love Republicans you know they love do I
I don't I don't know I don't know I
don't know
I think you're being sarcastic I think
you gotta love the fact that when they
say
just comply you must comply um
but then on the flip of the coin there
you've got Peter Navarro's like I don't
have to comply with [__] when it comes
to the subpoena Donald Trump says after
he surrendered himself will be arrested
he said uh we will not comply now
whether you're talking about covet you
complied You Gotta Be You got a vaccine
shot you got a booster or you're talking
about getting arrested you scheduled
yourself to show up at Fulton County and
you got your ass arrested Peter Navarro
doesn't have an option anymore he has to
show up and he's not winning because
this whole time even last year I think
it might have been my third third
episode of what was that it was focused
wait wait that's crazy
hold that thought you've been doing what
was that for over a year that's [__]
nuts man yeah I've we got some big
announcements on that but yeah yeah go
ahead go ahead uh yeah I just I just
actually I just hit episode 67.
yeah I mean that's pretty well we're at
we're at 473. well yeah we're gonna go
every day we're barreling in on 500 man
that's crazy go ahead sorry
Peter Navarro was episode
three if I remember correctly this is
when he got this is when they did the
contempt of congress this is the first
time when he was like I'm I'm not gonna
show up why do I need to show up and at
the time I made a comment that I was
like if you just let him talk long
enough
he's going to put himself in even
further legal Jeopardy I mean when he's
down why isn't what Trump Ally isn't
here yeah no I know I mean like
obviously with these cases but I mean
but even back then some of them are like
I'm not going to do anything and I'm
going to keep my mouth shut and I was
like oh that's a pretty smart move
but on the same side like on the other
end of that is is when Peter Navarro was
like I'm not gonna show up and then he
went all the he went on C Bannon show he
wanted his own show he went on Newsmax
he was on oan every place on MSNBC
admitting the crime on yeah he was on
already
like you do realize what you just did
right he's like no no no that's not no
no I didn't admit to a crime I didn't
admit to a crime and you're like that's
what you did man and Ari is going to
described a coup Ari's one of the
smartest lawyers on TV he really is like
he's one of the sharpest smartest
lawyers on TV and he like in those and
he did it like three or four times like
three or four days in a row Navara went
on there and admitted to crime and Ari's
like keep coming on man keep keep doing
it yeah and each time he was like look
this is the last time you came on this
is what you said anyway right well
that's not I mean and it's the same same
strategy Republicans have every single
one of them especially rivet ramaswamy
they're always like that's not actually
what I said what I said was this like
all right pull up the clip let's play
the clip here at the audio recording
here's a transcript he goes now see
you're you're you're you're you're
misrepresenting taking it out of content
you're manipulating what I said he's
like we just played it unedited right
this is what you said right no no no no
no that's not you know
every one of these every one of these
Republicans will always play that game
but God is not what I said and then our
email was like okay well let's just play
the clip from last time this is what you
said and he goes okay you're taken out
of context you don't understand what I'm
saying and I was like I'm a goddamn
lawyer man and I'm I have a better
reputation than you do right and I was
here yet and I was here yesterday when
you said it yeah and I've got a team of
people that went line by line word by
word of what you said so good luck well
speaking of playing the clip you got to
watch the rest of this this this woman
is a true patriot and a true hero
because she does not back down oh by the
way the truth conductor he was their
last last June yeah he was there in the
background if people go back to June
2022 you're talking about the guy
holding the sign and he was the one
asking her to have him speak let him
speak he's been at some other places but
he's been at Peter Navarro's every time
I haven't I didn't see him at the last
one
but if you go all the way back to end of
May or June 2022 when he's he's got his
first leg I show up to court and I'm not
doing [__] kind of thing right he's
there in the background
well let's see after he got arrested he
was like oh they took me in shackles it
was like no they didn't
oh yeah you're talking about Navarro
yeah Navarro claimed that he's like they
they put me in shackles total disrespect
the FBI and everyone's like wait wait
are you calling are you saying Peter
Navarro is a liar I'm not saying he's a
liar but he might be a big Fibber You
Know It uh lie he's a liar he's like
okay okay let's watch let's watch how
she handles the liar here it's [__]
phenomenal so which with a broom
let me go back
to speak about serious constitutional
issues with you
clown with a whistle which would have
been
playing with the whistle
so cloud of the whistle and a witch with
a broom oh man I hope she has a sign I
hope she has a sign next time that says
I'm the witch with the broom because
it's today he's in court today so
hopefully she'll do that I think I
actually think that the clown with the
whistle and the witch with the broom the
two people that those are actually
uh descriptors them describing would be
Marjorie Taylor green is a clown with
the whistle yeah and Lauren bobert is a
witch with a broom that is pretty good I
mean tell me I mean geez Margie Taylor
green is a clown and she's been defeated
multiple times by a dude with the
whistle right running away running
running away and Lauren bobert is a
goddamn witch man if you've seen some
photos of her it looks like she's got
that pointy chin it very much it really
reminds me of the wicked witch you know
from uh
I'm just I'm just saying dude she they
are very similar you're not saying she's
the Witch and Wizard of Oz but you're
saying we should investigate all I'm
saying is there if there was someone out
there who's listening to this right now
Russia I hope you're listening uh if
there's anyone listening right now
behind me 50 000 emails
put Lauren bobert
in green makeup
and and tell me she does not look like
the wicked witch
oh my God I mean already I I once put uh
Kevin McCarthy as the Cowardly Lion
because that's what he is he is then he
is that every time we say something on
here Discord lights up like now it's
full of Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bobert memes you're welcome just like
that that's what are you saying all I'm
saying is
it's it's accurate okay let's let's
let's finish the clip and then I want to
get to uh the great news the great
expansion news that we have here well
let's finish this clip with Pierre
Navarro listen to the very end it's like
the cherry on top uh
defendpeter.com please go there help the
support this fighting against uh the
attack on a separation of powers these
trials are very expensive
laughs
[Music]
these uh these trials are very expensive
that's part of the Democrats welfare
against us
there we go every time there's a lie she
pulls the Whistler
[Music]
yeah it's time to go all right we'll see
you tomorrow yeah
hopefully
oh my God he's so triggered this is so
[__] funny
she's like I'll see you tomorrow she's
like yeah I will too same time same
place [__]
I wish you would have said same time
same place Surf's Up [__] oh my
god when she did that same time
good man the fact that these people
these Republicans this whole time this
whole time they're like oh man we're
[__] Alpha we're tough guy we're
Macho you can't break us down we'll show
you what happens they're in court they
cry like little [__] they ask for
forgiveness and try to plead their way
out Peter Navarro and other people can't
take a goddamn whistle they either run
away close up shop or say oh I can't
speak uh because they're they're they're
infringing they're they're suppressing
My First Amendment rights I can't speak
out how no it seemed like he could speak
fine I don't know what I mean don't
don't be a little baby right and speak
up right use your voice speak up a bit
if you wanna try right if you don't want
to have people approach you on a public
sidewalk maybe you shouldn't set your
your press conference up on a public
sidewalk you [__] idiot maybe you
should maybe you should use a little bit
of that money that you're grifting to
rent a private conference room and have
a private press conference where you
could where you can be heard otherwise
if you're going to stand in public that
would mean that he would have to show
that he paid money oh or something that
he wasn't grifting because we have to
remember that if you go to defend Peter
uh he instantly got that domain
defendpeter.com he's raised
448 thousand dollars and his goal is
five a 495 because if you remember
in June of 2022 when he was like I was
arrested they put me in shackle so
disrespect all that [__] he was like
it'll cost me half a million dollars he
was saying it back then
and that's he put it just shy because
you know what
if you if you donate on gifts and go
he'll take off a very very small percent
so instead of 500 000 it'll be 495 000
right so that's how you know he cares
about you that one percent difference
well here's here's the report this
morning uh six hour goes from uh our
friend Scott McFarland
um he says trial begins shortly here at
the federal courthouse in the contempt
of congress case a former Trump advisor
Peter Navarro now this is important for
the audience to know 18 months after
Navarro snubbed The subpoena from the
house January 6 committee I want you I
want you to just let that sink in this
is 18 months
after he did the crime of contempt of
crime what about what about that
two-tier justice system dude well again
I keep I keep reminding people this is
the federal system and the federal
system is not fast it's not fast it
works very slowly that is actually the
design of it if you want to know the
honest truth once someone waves their
right to a speedy trial in a federal
court it is very slow process to get
someone to a trial now they may plea and
that may cause it to happen really fast
but Peter Navarro is going to trial like
everyone expects Donald Trump to go to
trial so if you do the math if you just
do the math
and you're like oh well then it's
probably oh boy these trials are going
to take a long time to get to it's going
to take a long time to get to this step
I mean if enough of us commit crimes
then I might be able to save myself a
few months here and there right where I
don't have to show up right well that's
like this story about uh Donald Trump
the prosecutors have alerted judkin to
his true social post but again you're
going to be disappointed in that and I
don't think Judson is going to do [__]
about this she may get in court and
reprimand him again
she's going to remind lauro of why it's
important that Donald Trump not
intimidate Witnesses just like she did a
few weeks ago it's always going to
happen I just don't see anything
happening and and she'll disappoint a
lot of people but uh here here uh we are
finally getting Justice with this
contempa Congress case but if you
remember
Steve Bannon was convicted of this the
same thing and he's still out walking
around on appeal so if you believe that
which Peter Navarro is likely to be have
the same fate as Bannon on his
conviction it's going to be very quick
it's not going to take long for trial
the the jury's not going to take long to
go yeah you're guilty of that I mean
what's your defense that that you didn't
like the law I mean that's not an that's
not an excuse that's not a defense that
you didn't like the law and and really
honestly Navarro's case is slimmer than
bannon's because Bannon actually had
Trump claiming executive privilege in
that case Navarro does not there is
nowhere in this case where Trump has
claimed any kind of executive privilege
for so for him to use that for an event
it's ridiculous anyways so he is facing
the same fate but folks if you're
looking to be disappointed then expect
expect tomorrow to be in jail because
he's probably not going to be they're
going to let him out on a PO just like
they did [__] Bannon it's it and
again if you want disappointment then
there's where to seek it but if you want
just you know what this is the [__] and
we can use this like that video that
woman oh my God you I I would rather
Peter Navarro have to walk around
everywhere with her standing right next
to him for the rest of his life then see
him in prison that would please me more
than anything like really honestly
prison because what is he gonna get
maybe three or four months maybe a year
but they're probably not much I mean you
know
was Bannon did Ben again sentenced and
then he appealed is that what it was
yeah I remember one I I I don't remember
exactly what this I I'd have to go back
and look to remember
um but the point is is that even I think
a year is like the max that they can get
for this for this contempt of congress
yeah he got uh as of our that was
October 21st but he was Banning with
sentence today to four months of
encourage operation in order to pay a
fine of 6500 on two counts of contempt
of congress stemming from his failure to
comply with subpoena issued by the house
like committee so so it's likely Navarro
will have sworn of the same fate five
six months maybe three months something
like that and he'll be out on appeal and
he'll be it the sentence will be shorter
than the appeal process I mean this is a
almost a year ago right but here's the
thing here's the thing is that I would
rather sentence Navarro to no prison
just to have her stand next to him and
just blow a whistle anytime he says a
word I mean set up a gifts and go for
her just to go around Navarro after
lunch that's a hell outside his house
when he's at the courthouse walking
around you know in the park all any
moment possible have a whistle have a
sign it's like the opposite of a hype
man you know right where you've got this
you've got this person that is there to
make everyone aware of how shitty this
person is I wish we could do the same
thing with Trump but in front well I
actually have a clip that I'm going to
play after announcement here of a hype
man this is a beautiful this is a
beautiful clip too I love this clip um
but first I want to get into the news
now everyone everyone in the show you
the audience has been here for a long
time and I can't believe that you've
been doing what was that for over a year
that's crazy yeah yeah and that's it I
started I started with the Uvalde
shooting right that was the very first
one yeah wow and that was only a week
after that or two weeks it was no it was
less it was it was like within a week of
that yeah because you what you were
planning it uh we we we worked on this
and you worked on this for months to
figure out what was it gonna be because
what you wanted to do
and I want to tell the audience kind of
like behind the scenes Gabe's like I
want to do something that feels like
late night it it because he wanted to
produce something that was heavily
produced he loves details he loves
Easter eggs this guy worked he worked
for months to figure out what this thing
was going to be we went back and forth
like names you were trying to choose I
mean he's he was sending me like what
about this graphic what about this what
about this how about this and I mean he
just kept sending me stuff and he worked
so hard on this on to figure out what
what was it what was that what what was
that actually was
and he finally came out with the with
Uvalde and and you've done this is 67
you said the next one I'm doing will be
68. 68 so you've had 67. okay 67 in a
can and he aired a lot of these on the
mind to touch network but he's been
airing them on his YouTube channel as
well and his YouTube channel has been
taking off especially with the patreon
and the Sunday
um yeah
yeah so so what Gabe is going to do
um because this is taking fire is Gabe
is gonna give us a third hour here at
the show uh three days a week so let me
show the folks the schedule and I'm
going to tell you how this is going to
work all right so you kind of got it uh
mapped out here now I'm going to give an
hour as well so we're gonna do three
hours a day because we're trying to
figure out how to get three hours a day
for the audience and one way that we're
gonna do that is on Tuesday Wednesday
and Thursday how are you expanding the
[__] fan Universe here is you guys
are gonna get an hour of Gabe Sanchez
live doing aren't you calling it what
was that live what are you calling yeah
I'm gonna call it what was that live so
so it's not like the what was that it's
just you're just gonna be doing topics
um kind of like what was that but live
for a full hour after our show here on
the Tony mangoes podcast so here's
what's gonna happen folks just like we
did on the patreon the last few weeks
our show the attorney Michael's podcast
is going to go directly into Gabe
Sanchez's what was that live so we're
you're gonna get three full hours of
Tony and Gabe when it comes to Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday now I'm gonna be
doing a pre-show on Monday and Friday uh
for patreon only so you'll be able to do
three hours all five days a week from
Monday through Friday but mine will be a
pre-show so I'm gonna do a pre-show on
Monday and Friday we'll have the two
hour show like we do now and then on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday we're gonna
cut to Gabe Sanchez now Gabe tell I'm
excited about this I'm freaking excited
about this this is this is going to be
something that the audience is going to
love because not only not only is it an
hour full of Gabe yeah it is it is over
on your channel it is over on your
channel your channel is growing like
crazy the what was that is getting tons
of views
um it's catching fire they're getting
better and better and better they really
are so but how excited are you about
um having the hour with the audience and
what was it yeah it's it's great uh you
know the last last couple Sundays you
know I put it open just to kind of let
people know what I was doing on the
patreon and you know would come in on
Sunday say hello during yours and then
switch over to mine and the amount of uh
positive reception and the amount of
people who are like this is great I love
it you know uh the engagement that I'm
able to have on the show because it also
I think the other thing too is like it
gives people a perspective of how
oh like a like some people on patreon
have seen it before like how my mind
works when figuring out a story
especially if there's something I
haven't learned before or heard that
somebody's bringing up then I'll look
into it and then the people can see it
kind of live but yeah so the idea is
that people will be able to follow along
we'll touch on topics some might overlap
with Tony obviously you know different
takes different perspectives on stuff uh
but it will be a more you know it's
current events politics and other things
that'll come out you know
um I'm I think I've got a I want to end
it with like a like a weird crazy funny
what was that like a good like well no
on a good note you know we've had a
couple of those moments the last couple
sessions that we've done
um
but just getting the getting the
community involved and people seem to be
really liking it the channel is
definitely growing I'm almost at 10K now
um so the latest the latest episodes and
the latest lives that I've done have
really taken off uh and like I said
people have really been receptive to
what we've been doing over there and I'm
really excited and and especially
because now you'll catch me during the
day as opposed to in the morning or at
night on a Sunday so yeah I'm I'm
excited this is great you know what I
think is best about it is like so many
times during the show there's something
that happens on the show and we watch a
clip and you're like uh now I gotta do a
what was that yeah yeah and there's like
a whole list of what was that that you
can't get to right yeah so now so now
you're going to be able to work through
these topics on the hour after our hour
yeah and and that you can't get to with
a with the what was that piece of
content right yeah I think that's the
best part about it is that there's going
to be a really getting there get in
these topics like yeah and that's the
other thing too is having the ability
ability to react to those stories in
real time like you might follow me along
as I salute the internet right as you
know you might follow me as I'm digging
into Rudy Giuliani or Donald Trump or
Marjorie Taylor green or any of these
other [__] clowns
uh so you'll be able to get that live
but then also you know and I might not
be able to do a whole episode on
something until more of a story develops
but at that moment I can be like all
right let's figure out like what was
that like what did they say what did
they do that's that's [__] crazy
right why are they back with the tape
and let's let's go over it again so yeah
it's really exciting for that reason
especially because
there's a lot of questions coming in
Brendan Lewis asked a good question will
Gabe still be a part of Tony show he's
always going to be part of the show here
what are you talking about he's part of
the [__] fam that's the whole point
we'll be around yeah but here's the
thing on Mondays he's going to help
co-host and on Fridays we gotta do
bonehead of the week yeah we can't not I
can't abandon my baby right that's
Gabe's original baby is bonehead of the
week I mean bone of the week was pre
what was that I mean that's like his
first kid what was it it's like you know
the second kid you know he did better at
the second kid than the people yeah you
try it yeah yeah
but you learn a lot and then the second
gets better but no he's still gonna be
on bone into the week he won't be here
as much Tuesday Wednesday Thursday but
you're gonna come on and and talk to us
a little bit before we shoot to your
show yeah just I'll still be honestly
it's still going to be here well I'll
still be on at the end of the show on on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday uh and then
and then I'll pop off for a second and
then I'll see you again for the third
hour right on my channel all for the
what was that live there's there's so
many logistical things like in Discord
they're like so what are we going to do
where are we going to live chat in
Discord the whole Discord someone
someone said PornHub that they're gonna
go over to Pornhub and look if I don't
know how to live stream on PornHub I
might try to be you gotta like apply
it's like a yeah a talent into it but
for people who want to know are they
still chatting on Tony's Discord I have
a Discord I'll put that uh I'll put that
link in here right now I'll put it you
know what I'll put the link for my desk
in the Discord the Discord yeah that's
perfect that's perfect that's perfect
um Brent Brendan also brought up a good
point [__] it do it live do it live have
you ever yeah have you seen it that's
what I I literally have that as my uh
countdown is that is that what's going
is that what's going it counts down a
minute and a half to two minutes and at
the very end it's it's O'Reilly going
what is it what does it mean play me up
[__] it we'll do a live we'll do it live
and then the intro plays and that's me
boom so here's how it's gonna work
here's how it's gonna work
um and here I'll put the schedule up one
more time so you can see it on Mondays
I'll have a pre-show now this is all
starting next week I have a pre-show
it's 11 to 12 Eastern if you want to get
on that go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or go to the Tony michaels.com
click on the patreon link you'll get in
on that the show is going to be exactly
the same it's going to be free it's
going to be where it's been all the time
the Tony Michaels podcast and then
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
as soon as my show is over as soon as
the Tony Michaels podcast is over that
link is going to go directly to Gabe's
show what was that live it'll go
directly to his show and then on Friday
it'll be like it is Monday and then
we'll end the week with bonehead of the
week just like we do every week right
now so I'm super excited about this
expansion I am so happy that this
content is taking off I and I've told
Gabe this in private but I'll say it out
loud I believe in this piece of content
he's worked so hard on it uh he's gotten
better and better each episode he's
learned a lot uh through trial and error
on on how to make this content exactly
what it needs to be not just to get the
views and the clicks but for you guys to
really enjoy this piece of content this
what was that and and I tell you he puts
a ton of effort into it it's it has
since I mean even since the Peter
Navarro third episode I did or the first
episode with Vivaldi uh it has morphed
right and changed I've changed
backgrounds I tried new layouts I did
different setups I mean you know what
you know what uh you know what we should
do if anyone in the disc and I know
Discord is always listening but anyone
in the Discord we should this afternoon
they should screen the Peter Navarro
what was that from the episode three
they should screen that so everyone can
go oh you know what actually that's that
episode has
I think it has my first
first gag that I do really the first
physical gag I have a moment there's
actually there might be two moments
actually really yeah I have in there so
so we should screen we should screen
that on on our Discord or on Gage
Discord whichever yeah whichever
whichever works best whatever I I it
doesn't matter to me just pick a place
and and we'll see we should screen that
this afternoon and maybe me and Gabe
will show up is that how long is that
one it's like eight minutes
they used to be a little shorter but
then it got to where these chuckle heads
there's so much [__] that you had to go
10 12. there's there are so many moments
when I write something and I'm like that
won't work I gotta I gotta all right
or sometimes I come back after the fact
like if I'm editing and I'm waiting on a
small detail I'm like oh [__] okay I
gotta do a quick voice over on a graphic
right because there was some little some
little [__] show thing that blew up you
know what's crazy is when you first when
you first pitch this to me because
you're like this is what I want to do
I'm like all right well I think you can
do it and because it was like a late
[__] late night show like Daily Show or
set yeah I wanted to have something that
was like Daily Show or Last Week Tonight
kind of I did you know it had that yeah
that late night feel to it and with the
jokes and the and you know the the clips
and stuff and I was thinking the whole
time like how in the [__] is this guy
gonna do this all on like they have full
teams like shed Myers and The Daily Show
they got a whole team of people doing
this [__]
Gabe is one dude one
one and and in the beginning I think you
sent me a couple of the scripts and I
was like uh maybe change this this and
this but ever maybe past episode 10 I
have not done anything Gabe has done the
entire [__] I did nothing nothing
absolutely no it's all him every single
bit of it so he is an entire late night
show team producing this thing all by
himself one you were like hey who who's
editing who's who's writing who's
filming it's all me guys I do it all
myself just him you know that is why
that's why the patreon is so important
that's right that's right
without it
I wouldn't be able to do what I do right
now and the same thing goes for Tony the
the ability to do this every day and
and create the content that we do that's
why the patreon is so important to us or
that's why the YouTube memberships are
so important because it helps literally
fund and produce the content that we
crank we are funded by viewers like you
as they say I think it's PB is that PBS
or NPR is that we're fun I think it's
PBS I think it's PBS we're funded by
viewers like and I'll steal it I don't
care well let's do that let's do that so
so make sure you're supporting Gabe uh
again go to
iamgabesanchez.com that'll get him there
I am Gabe sanchez.com all the links it's
also if you I also changed my I'm
watching the clip right now
and I changed my like uh
he's really nervous you seem really
nervous that they're gonna screen this
thing no no no no no what I'm saying is
like you'll see how much I changed it
you'll see how much I changed it like
like physically the layout but also my
delivery is totally different now like
everything is way different it took it
took a lot of episodes to get there I
mean Jesus Christ I've we've been doing
this for 473. this show and if you go
back and you watch like episode 10 or go
listen to episode 10 or something you're
like what the [__] this is not the same
as it was because it takes a little bit
to get to get there it takes a little
bit to get there it takes a little bit
to get there you know yeah yeah you
gotta you know it's it's all also your
words like what do people respond to
it's a [__] psychology thing you
gotta really think about it that's why I
spend so much time writing this [__] man
I write jokes I rewrite jokes I rewrite
I rewrite jokes it's
it's great and you know the thing about
um the guy with the last name Sanchez is
this guy picks apart every single every
[__] detail like there's times like
um because I'm gonna be doing a lot of
the thumbnails for the show now so
you're gonna notice the quality of the
the thumbnails for the Tony Michaels
podcast they're gonna go down just a bit
for a little bit until I get some
practice because Gabe Sanchez is one
thing he's really good at is finding the
best faces of like Trump or whoever
these idiots are that's why the bone of
the week thing like all the graphics
it's it's I have to show their true
selves right I know I know but every
little detail like sometimes he'll send
me like he'll send me a thumbnail I'm
like all right I'm gonna go post the
show and I'm gonna get the show going
and you guys see the thumbnail on the
link come up and like Brian at the last
minute he's like no no no no no no wait
a second I had to adjust this thing and
it's like I'm like what the [__] is the
difference and he's like no it says I'm
like Jesus Christ No One's Gonna notice
he's like oh yeah they will oh
out there that's gonna notice the same
little detail it could be the brightness
it could be the contrast it could be
something that's in the photo itself
literally to make sure that it's good
and let me tell you something like any
because I'm horrible at spelling
horrible at it and I don't give a [__]
like I don't care if I post something
that's got a spelling error in it or
something I don't care I'm not deleting
that [__] but anytime anytime there's
just the slightest just the slightest
Mis step on on you know spelling or
something oh my God yep nope gotta
change it gotta change it so that's dude
I don't know what's going on here
there's like massage gifts happening in
the Discord right now I don't know what
because because I said you you gotta
massage it that's why you gotta work it
yeah
you know what I mean I literally we just
say one word and the [__] Discord
chat goes crazy you want to do the
Discord and it's I was like what the
[__] sex scene is
again again folks if you're not on the
Discord you are missing out on some wild
stuff those I when I say those people
need Jesus over there I'm dead serious
maybe Jesus in a certain kind of way in
a certain kind of way uh speaking of
needing Jesus so again stick with the
schedule this is all next week Monday if
you let me do it we'll continue to talk
about this we'll continue to tell you
about this
um every everything will fall into place
it's going to be a huge expansion it's
going to be it's gonna be what you guys
have been wanting which is a third hour
um and and and I hope this is a way that
we can give it to you that that helps
not just not just get our message out
there but also helps you guys with the
content it helps Gabe it helps me it
expands to show it expands the [__]
fam we love you guys that's what we're
here about so this is not Gabe leaving
the show this is an expansion of the
[__] fam and the [__] em Universe it
really truly is
yeah speaking of growing Donald Trump
really looks like he's getting bigger
doesn't need Jesus Christ this guy well
you know that's what happens when
everyone says she big it everyone says
not the fat Shaman but I can't I can't
help but notice how much dumpier he's
getting am I wrong he's a little frumpy
like he's you know hunched over bad
posture he's almost as bad as that one
guy William Morgan that we looked at
yesterday
who barely made it above the well look
at this guy what are you guys talking
about does he have his pants pulled up
to his tits I mean this is these are
really high he's got a girl like a
little was it a girdle girl yeah well
you know he's got to tuck it in and it's
not well he's got in the Spanx you know
he puts on the Spanx and he's like well
I can't go to the bathroom for hours now
because
it's a whole ordeal to get it on it's
easy when you got a diaper you know what
I mean you know it's like it's like when
you're you have someone helping you like
uh with like raking the leaves and
you're putting them in so you got maybe
someone or two people holding a bag open
and then you like kind of do like that
that's what I imagine is happening oh
God here's what here's what happens on
Discord here's what happens on Discord
we start talking about fat Trump and fat
Trump memes just start pouring in if you
want your best political memes Discord
is the place to go yeah it really is
okay so this video here is Donald Trump
talking and I think this is at
Mar-A-Lago
I think or no is this this is betminster
this is what this is
okay so and this this lady that he's
talking to here he's holding the
microphone for this is the leader of
bikers for Trump I think is what the
group is called I mean I do say Trump
2024 right something I see him with
sunglasses on and I don't know something
be something you'll be right it's very
delusional t-shirt right but but here's
the thing is is that um
he's talking to this lady who is the
leader of the bikers for Trump or
something
but you know what I noticed about this
before I even played it I'm like Trump
would never ever ever stand this close
to this woman never in a million years
no way unless he put himself in a
position where he is a pariah and no one
wants anything to do with him right
where he has to stand next to her you
know what I mean
but it's really weird the interaction
here in this clip uh of trump and this
lady yeah well let me just play it yeah
I have no idea what's going on so I'm
curious to see it's not that long but
they got a microphone so they gotta have
an audience that they're talking to but
watch see if you can tell his reaction
when she goes to like touch him that's
wow
hurry
and we also fight against the people
trying to get you and we love you
get anyone fighting against us
statues did she say statues and Longs I
think she said we yell out statues and
laws you notice you notice when he's
standing here Gabe's engines how
uninterested he is and what she's saying
this looks like a man who is six three
and 215 pounds of pure Patriots
I'm sorry but I I I just want to know
also I had the same question Michelle in
the chat said this I wonder the same
thing is that a stethoscope in the
pocket or is that like a like a radio or
something I I think I think it's I think
it's uh um earbuds I think it's what it
is okay because I'm not sure no Michelle
you're not alone when I first saw the
clip when we first even before we played
it I was like is that a stethoscope is
this person a doctor God damn it is this
a doctor that came from Sturgis that
spread covered in Sturgis at the biker
gang rally
bikers for Trump oh my God these AI
photos of Donald Trump Jesus Christ
somebody's on AI oh my God if we're
break Jesus if we're breaking up
laughing and because we're looking at
the Discord oh my god oh okay so so the
other thing that happens here really
fast is um this lady goes to try to
touch him and like touch him on the arm
you know like when you're standing next
to someone and you're like complimenting
them or you're talking to them and
you're trying to like touch them on the
arm you know like you know show them
that you know you love them or something
but watch watch what happens it's it's
funny that's with all the landings what
rules so they can't they can't fight
with me obviously they can't fight with
you this is America
[Applause]
[Music]
he's like give me that [__]
microphone
uncomfortable he was when she I felt
uncomfortable she was like yeah so yeah
baby yeah baby it's just like why are
you why are you okay look
I don't like Trump I hate the [__]
guy but even I would feel uncomfortable
someone was stroking my like tricep area
or my forearm you know like what are you
doing why are you doing that why not
just like a Pat or like a on the
shoulder or something like that she
touched him on the hip too she's like
dude oh man oh man it's probably because
he's he's it's probably because he's
seven three 195 pounds that's probably
why she had to because really honestly
this lady's almost six foot tall that's
the thing that we're not talking about
here is this lady's almost six foot tall
look how much taller he is than her I
mean look at this he's he's a he's a
[__]
he's a specimen he's a specimen oh my
God I can't believe how dumpy he looks
and how old he looks and they're like
Joe Biden Joe baden's so old I'm like
this this is old man what are you
talking about dude
it's just
it's so oh my God this guy's a [__]
idiot but also it's so weird and he is
holding on this is a man who is holding
on for dear life for any moment he can
get where people acknowledge Him or he's
relevant or anything of the of the
nature where somebody's like oh my God
Donald Trump and they don't have to they
don't have anything shitty to say about
him like oh my God Donald Trump
he's holding on that's like you know
once people like oh when when people are
you know they're told like they're gonna
die in three years because of cancer
something gets incurable like sometimes
they say that people are out able to
outlive that because of the pure hate
that they have for whatever it might be
Donald Trump is the same way except
death is knocking on the door for him on
the door that's literally behind him
right now that's like trying to get in
or trying to get out of marlag or
Bedminster and Donald Trump is like
barely holding on as he as he [__]
clings clings on to any sort of like
relevance or popularity or anyone who
has anything to say about him like hey
how you doing he's like oh yes that's
what I needed oh [__] and again again 20
years ago Donald Trump wouldn't even let
this lady stand on this doorstep not at
all Garen damn TV he would have security
x x escort her off the property if this
person that looked like this and talk
like this and act like this was standing
on this doorstep he'd like get her the
[__] out of here I don't want her
anywhere near me but he is he has done
this to himself to where he is these are
the people the quality of the quality
because remember I mean even though he
said he's like I love the uneducated the
quality of people that he Lakes are very
different than the ones that he was able
to have before like you know even when
he was early on in his career and then
well that video that video of him and
Jeffrey Epstein at the party where he's
like yeah yeah okay oh man look at him
teenagers over there Jeffrey he's like
Jeff you want to turn with my daughter
we should go over there to your island
with some of these teenagers you know
that video that he's in but you look at
Donald Trump and you see how in the
beginning he was popular everyone knew
him ever you know uh he was he had
influence back then then he like dropped
down then he got The Apprentice people
like oh yeah Donald do the Cobra you're
fired you know that kind of [__] became
popular again and then you know went
back and forth to the birther movement
got made fun of got embarrassed that's
pretty much that in the White House
correspondence Center when Obama was in
office
pretty much was like the origin story of
him trying to run for president but as
you've seen he's gone from like an elite
status
down to the common people but only
because these common people are the only
ones that are willing to accept him or
be within reaching stroking distance
right whoa easy on this I'm just saying
the stroking dude
easy on the stroking talk let's finish
this up Strokes for Trump folks you know
that's true it's true but watch watch
how awkward he is when he tries to say
something here because he doesn't know
what to say because he hates this he
[__] hates this watch
yeah
but in the meantime
[Applause]
he didn't know what he's like yeah yeah
you're my supporter right he he created
this situation
this guy created I got a Skype of people
that's that's he I mean dude man he got
them yeah it's almost it's almost like
he took a course at hustle like Hustlers
University okay
the same thing that Andrew Tate teaches
and and learned how to disrespect people
but then also make those people then
want him even more I
take Discord
while I'm doing this show you [__]
over there
I'm gonna come oh yeah oh my God look at
that dude oh my God these gifts oh my
God The Strokes someone asked uh Gabe's
Discord someone dropped Dave's gave
Dave's Gabe's Jesus Christ you could
someone someone I can't help it the
[__] Discord chance got me all
discombobulated here
someone put Gabe's Discord in the live
chat there someone throw that in there
one more time so people can go see that
because because you're not gonna Wanna
Miss a single thing here
the [__] shavings one oh man
they're crazy over there on Discord so
you're definitely going to want to get
in on the Discord the Tony Michaels
podcast Discord and Gabe's Discord
because what we're gonna do again on
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday after the
show here two full hours on Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday you get an extra hour
of Gabe Sanchez with what was that live
it'll direct directly to him if you're
watching on YouTube and on Twitch too
right uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
last the last few times I've I've
streamed to Twitch and I updated I
updated the chat so people who are on
Twitch
find me there it's at I am Gabe Sanchez
you can find me at all platforms at I am
Gabe Sanchez do it do it do it follow
subscribe hit that like smash that
whatever button do whatever you want
here's the thing for all the people on
Facebook because there's a lot of people
that watch on Facebook
Gabe does not have a Facebook page I
don't do that Facebook man so if you
want to share the YouTube stuff to
Facebook right ahead so so if you want
to watch if you're on Facebook watching
or you watch on Facebook you're going to
want to go get on YouTube uh are you
going to want to get on Twitch after the
show is over so you can watch Gabe over
there and chat with him uh while you do
that now they also stream this stuff in
the Discord and so so it's streamed into
Discord too live or you can get it on
the live chat there on Gabe's Discord
during his hour or during the two hours
of the Tony Michaels podcast and again
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday you're just
gonna stay right here so like when I do
Surf's Up [__] and then the
music and then and then maybe an Easter
egg after that happens it'll go directly
to Gabe's and then he'll start because
I'll I'll message him like Hey you're
you're on
you're on it's yeah live do it live do
it live do it live and then you'll get
dumped right into Gabe's show so you
won't if you're on YouTube or twitch you
won't have to go anywhere I mean you
ought to do the raid on Twitch but
everyone's gonna do that anyways on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday but on
YouTube directly into it when we end the
episode so I'm I am I'm super excited
I'm super happy for you man honestly I
think I think uh that what was that
piece of content is going to be a huge
piece of content uh it's going to get
millions of views it's already got
millions of views I I hope and I I think
I think you're gonna get the [__] fam
to support you 100 and I I know I know
we're gonna gain even more of an
audience by doing what we're doing and
more people are gonna come and be
members of the [__] family support
the [__] fam and get in on the
Discord get on the YouTube chat the
twitch chat Facebook on during my show
you know
we're gonna get we're gonna get Gabe to
open up a Facebook page it's gonna
happen it's not gonna it's gonna it's
gonna happen it's not gonna happen it's
gonna happen I'm just gonna let you know
gonna come to Facebook everyone just
like you should come here tomorrow same
time same place
surf sub [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon